[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
شكرًا لك
إنه يشعر بالسعادة، وهو محظوظ لأنه في ظل
النقص السيئ في الإصابة بفيروس نقص المناعة البشرية وسرطان الدم،
ساعده التدخل في التخلص من
كليهما، لذلك يشعر بأنه محظوظ وسعيد
جدًا  لمشاركة هذه الأخبار مع
أشخاص آخرين مصابين بفيروس نقص المناعة البشرية
في الخارج
مؤخرًا في وسائل الإعلام، لقد شفيت من فيروس الإيدز،
ما ستفعله عملية زرع الخلايا الجذعية
هو استبدال الخلايا المناعية
من المريض بخلايا مناعية
من المتبرع و  في حالة
الأشخاص المصابين بفيروس نقص المناعة البشرية، فهذا يعني أن
الجهاز المناعي من المتبرع سوف يحل
محل ويدمر الخلايا المناعية
التي تحمل فيروس نقص المناعة البشرية في
المريض، وبالتالي سيؤدي ذلك تدريجيًا
إلى القضاء على معظم الخلايا المصابة
الموجودة في الجسم.
أجنبي
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى] من
الواضح أن هذه نتيجة مثيرة ولكنها
ليست الحل العلاجي
للجميع لكل شخص مصاب
بفيروس نقص المناعة البشرية ولكن هذا يكفي بحيث
لدينا إمكانية إعادة إنتاج
نتيجة علاج فيروس نقص المناعة البشرية باستخدام التدخل العلاجي